welcome back to guess that letter i'm
your host mark wahlberg and uh we have
two great contestants here cody co and
uh noelle miller are here uh if you are
just joining us
uh they have horribly lost all four
rounds leading up to this
they missed the missing k in kodiko uh
the missing w in wtf and also
missed the missing s in wow
you guys suck at this game
uh but let's solder on shall we yeah
yeah you feeling pretty good oh yeah
yeah i'm feeling confident yeah enough
with the riffraff mark let's go oh okay
why don't we spin the wheel and see how
much money you're playing for
got it
a little english on it yeah let's go
okay
little english you said all right
one
two
three oh jolly good
made
all right okay okay
okay
if you can guess the letter um which you
haven't done so far you'll win 10
million dollars 10
million dollars 10 million yeah which is
we would have got 250 million on the
last one if we get that right
right just one letter yeah that's it one
letter 10 mil how hard could be
let's do it that's what i thought when i
showed up today let's play shall we here
is your
missing letter let's take a look
bats and this whole word is written out
except for this
one letter for 10 million dollars of
this phrase
right here
[Music]
yeah yeah i think it's you that's crunch
crunch yeah
so you're going to go with that's crunch
yeah
so it sounds right it has a nice ring to
it yeah it does it does have a nice ring
to it with the exception that it's not
actually a word
oh
so it's like it's like we're going to
try a different vowel yeah okay let's
try again yeah let's i mean let's go
with o let's i think it's probably a no
wait no what
it's a trick question
it's probably a number
oh
mark uh
we're gonna switch it up we're gonna go
to number six
so it's not a password
it's just a word and and let's remember
all of the things that could help you
like the name of the show is uh
guess that letter
oh you're right maybe it's an emoji yeah
the boat
the boat
um let's see if the boat is right
yeah no so that's not it yeah sorry um
i
think you should get this i think
if you pay attention
i think you may find a clue somewhere
that's what i
think
well i
yes think that i don't know what it is
yeah and i am getting pretty frustrated
so i think that we are going to guess e
final
final answer
that's your final answer
okay
show me an e
yeah so it's not e
um and i can't let the show end like
this because that would just be so
cringe
wait
we never guessed hey it's a [ __ ] a
that's crane that's cranes that's crazy
that's crazy
that's crazy
yeah we got it right
yeah you guys
are so [ __ ] dumb
oh that's all the time we have
you